[Music]
[Applause]
Holly Road was there on the sidelines
ESPN reporter also a winner of the Kurt
Gowdy award for outstanding reporting
and she was there on the sidelines for
the entire weekend with women's college
basketball and Holly kind enough to join
us from Los Angeles where she just
landed how would you describe the last
month for the sport of women's
basketball
the last month of the women's basketball
has been transfer
transectrifying and really good
basketball I have been very lucky to be
on the Caitlin Clark train I've been
doing games at Iowa I did her buzzer
beater she hit with 1.5 seconds left to
win a game against Indiana three weeks
ago and then I did her sweet 16 Elite
eight all the way up to the final four
watching her beat South Carolina and
then dropped 30 in a loss last night and
it's just been
I I just haven't seen anything like it
I've been covering women's basketball
for 30 years I have seen all of the
Contemporary greats and I was with Diana
Taurasi and Sue bird yesterday and and
they're even impressed so that should
tell you something but it's been really
cool
and then the story of LSU this is the
most improbable National Championship
you've ever seen in your life they had
one player on the roster this summer
these are all transfers and they won the
National Championship so it's been a
whirlwind but it's been really cool I
wonder what the reaction would have been
if you gave Caitlin Clark the most
outstanding player for the Final Four
you know the world would have gone crazy
because they think she gets too much
Star Treatment I I would argue she's
earned it she set the record for most
most points ever scored in the NCAA
tournament she's broken every record I
think her play on productivity deserves
it
um but I I see why they didn't I totally
get it and Angel Reese is a phenomenal
young woman I can't sing her Praises
enough she actually came and shadowed me
during college football this year
because she wants to do what I do and
she was so good on the sidelines she was
pointing out things she knew the game
she had several observations that were
important to my work and so Angel Reese
is a deserving most outstanding player
and she is a phenomenal young woman yeah
I I love that women women's basketball
got the uh the big stage and in some
ways overstaged the men's tournament
because you had some really good teams
storylines Caitlyn Clark but I don't
want the takeaway to be Angel Reese
holding up a ring finger to Caitlyn
Clark but it feels like that's going to
to be more than just a footnote here
Holly
I really am genuinely interested in this
because it seems like the people that
had the biggest problem with the trash
talking and the back story is Caitlyn
did this in their last round now she
didn't do it in somebody's face she did
the John Cena You Can't See Me
everybody thought it was hilarious John
Cena tweeted at her
um Angels was a little more in Caitlyn's
face I get that but why are older men so
offended by this I I really want to know
well they probably tuned in for the
first time
they probably thought oh gosh let me see
oh there's this little white girl and
she's acting like Pete Maravich and
Steph Curry and wow she's incredible and
not realizing that she is very
demonstrative on the floor you know
she's always going to the crowd I can't
hear you or holding up a three and and
she waved off the South Carolina uh girl
on the uh on the perimeter it it felt
like Angel was saying
you know what enough we deserve credit
you got you were over covered they can't
be mad at Caitlin Clark from the
standpoint of she brought eyeballs but I
think I thought I my feeling was LSU in
South Carolina were bothered by the over
coverage of Caitlyn Clark therefore
people didn't focus on these women on
these teams in their lives that was the
feeling
that's what people feel in their minds
I'll tell you this I personally I flew
overnight red eye slept in the airport
on the floor to get to Baton Rouge to do
a feature on Angel Reese January 24th
um I have flown to St Thomas to
personally do a feature on Aaliyah
Boston like we we have covered everybody
but some for some reason people get that
idea that that these other women don't
deserve coverage and that bothers me
because her productivity on the court
demands the coverage she received period
we misconstrue and this is the feeling I
got when I and I don't go on social
media but when it's sent to me then I'll
read but sportsmanship and gamesmanship
that
all of a sudden uh it felt like Angel
Reese needed to show sportsmanship
whereas it was okay for Caitlyn Clark to
have gamesmanship that that she could be
more taunting with you a little bit or
you know she has fun and I have no
problem with any of this stuff if I was
disappointed that angel used that moment
you just won the national title use that
moment with your team
don't don't do it for that you got the
ultimate scoreboard there but it felt
like she was tracking her down to put it
in her face and Caitlyn Clark to her
credit
just said okay look you had your day I'm
not going to acknowledge but how do we
not open up next season
with LSU in Iowa
and have a double header with a men's
game in a neutral sight Holly it's
that's the best idea you've had it's a
great idea here here's what there's a
couple of layers to this conversation
that I think are important number one if
this happened in a men's game would we
even be talking about it
uh we might depending on who it is but
we don't have it might have been a funny
meme it would have been a throwaway it
wouldn't have been a action but we don't
have stars in the men's game Holly
yeah it's interesting you know Patrick
Patrick Beverly does a lot of stuff um
Draymond Green all these guys do a lot
of stuff and we don't call them
classless all the time maybe sometimes
but so it bothers me that I think we
demand a certain Behavior by gender one
um number two for some reason I think
that we are only allowing black women to
behave a certain way that's not right
and Caitlyn Clark in her last game just
told her opponent that's a friend of
hers you're down by 15. shut up we
caught it on camera that became a meme
on the internet so I have no problem
with these young women talking trash to
each other that's Sports for the end of
time you know both of these women both
Caitlyn and Angel grew up playing on
boys teams they were both MVPs of two
separate boys teams Angel was an MVP of
her boys team with her brother that
played on it who now plays for Maryland
these women grew up playing with and
against the boys so I have no problem
with their behavior I really don't do I
wish Angel hadn't done it in that
particular moment so that that became
the story yeah maybe because I don't
want this to detract she is incredible
she has taken this team from absolutely
nothing and dragged them to a national
championship she's the one on the court
do this try harder she is the most
demanding in your face demanding
accountability Angel Reese won this
national championship by sheer will and
force and skill that's what I want us to
be talking about because I freaking love
her they should do maybe she does a uh
Kay's Jewelry commercial where she's
pointing at the finger and then they go
to Caitlin Clark and she's going are you
still doing that like you could do it if
you could have some nil money coming in
and I promise you Caitlyn taught so much
trash like she really does not in a
negative way she's funny I mean she's so
competitive
um I I don't I promise you Caitlin Clark
has no problem with this you know maybe
the moment maybe she's disappointed
about the loss today but the one person
who's not going to be on social media
Like Woe Is Me is Caitlin Clark because
she totally gets it
yeah it's weird I said when I started
the show if you think this is about race
then it's about you
it's about the person who is consuming
this if you see like I didn't go oh you
know a black girl can't act that way but
I just I didn't get caught up in uh the
only thing I thought was when you win
celebrate with your teammates don't make
it about you and Caitlin Clark use the
moment for the team because that's
that's who won her team won that
Championship not her without without the
bench that outscored Iowa 30 to eight
Holly they're not winning this year
championship take the moment to
celebrate that use the moment in in that
way
um I will say this Angel's hilarious and
and this just kind of goes with her like
if you really know her this goes with
her personality like I don't know if you
guys are up on this but she has a crown
with her on the bench like a certified
gold crown it's heavy I've worn it on my
head it sits on the bench and when she's
introduced for warm-ups they put the
crown on her head and you know I said to
Kim Mulkey two days ago I'm like are you
okay with the whole celebrate like how
have you had Angel be herself and this
big personality and she's like I have no
problem with it Angel performs she's my
best leader she's a great student I have
no problem with that I want her to have
a personality and you heard Kim in the
post-game interview with me last night
say I played with a lot of big
personalities and I've always believed
to win you have to let the big
personalities be who they are and that's
what you saw in that team that's why
they won Alexis Morris she was exactly
who she is Angel exactly who she is
um and that's the beauty of it so I you
know if the coach is willing to let the
players be who they are and celebrate it
sure then let's have the public you know
like let's let them have fun did you
have a celebrity experience on your
flight to Los Angeles
yes I had
I had to hang out today in LA on a
little day off girls Excursion and we
want to sit by each other on our flight
so we asked this very nice gentleman
that's sitting next to Maria do you mind
moving could you please move and it gets
up he moves all of his luggage you know
it's a whole thing
so so nice so we get off the flight
we're walking out and the woman in front
of us says do you all realize you just
made Johnny Gill from New Edition movie
so we're mortified we would like to say
thank you to um Mr Gill we will be
purchasing tickets to his show this
Saturday night in LA and we're very
sorry that's awesome it was very funny
it was very funny it's great to see you
thank you for having me and thanks for
talking about women's basketball
everybody has been so great so
supportive keep tuning in it is just
absolutely thrilling and let's get a
double header men's women's and and you
know ESPN runs college basketball you
can go to Jimmy if you don't think I'm
texting the program
and I would have the women's game be The
nightcap
yeah how would you come and do your show
from there if I can pull this off well
where are we gonna do it at some remote
area some exotic area or I mean if it's
their location probably
am I going to get some details let's
Circle that okay this is your baby and
you know you would love to have you
Holly thank you and uh it's great seeing
you thank you thanks for having me
hollyrow ESPN reporter and uh was the
winner of the Kirk Gowdy award for
outstanding reporting for the Mothership